[Music]
what happens when artists smash up two
of our favorite things we have some
awesome fan art that combines the loud
house in Disney Princesses into
something totally original stay tuned to
see the most creative loud house
princess crossover if you are a huge fan
of the loud house and all things Disney
subscribe to our Channel and don't
forget to like this video now let's get
to our 10 favorite Disney Princess and
loud house matchups LuAnn meets Belle
we are totally digging this awesome
mashup of LuAnn loud and Belle from
Beauty and the Beast this great fan art
is from the fresh Knight on deviantART
LuAnn is rocking Belle's hairstyle and
she looks super stylish in yellow it's
an interesting choice because LuAnn is a
total goof while Belle is more bookish
but we applaud the artist for being so
creative they really captured the
essence of both characters and we love
that the artist made the dress way more
LuAnn style than a ballgown seriously
this is the perfect definition of
crossover art how far I'll go with Lola
we are so excited to see Moana getting
some loud house Love on deviantART
this super cute piece is from the artist
Oh for starti corn on line 88 Lola looks
good outside of a pink princess dress
and we think Moana is the perfect nasha
both Murata and Lola loud will go far to
get what they want
they're both unwilling to let anyone
stop them and they're both total daddy's
girls we love seeing that gap-toothed
grin with a Polynesian twist and she
looks fabulous with that flower where
her tiara usually goes we wonder how
much mischief Lola would cause if she
was actually a princess the tomboy and
the Frog Tiana from The Princess and the
Frog is one of the most underrated
Disney Princesses were super glad to see
her included in funny times 77th
portfolio on deviantART lana loud loves
her frog hogs so mashing her up with the
frog kissing princess makes total sense
she looks snazzy and all green but even
as a princess
lonna wouldn't look right without her
signature baseball cap we're not sure
what sort of prince hops with make
though just like lana
tiana is a girl who isn't afraid to get
her hands dirty to get what she wants we
think this is an amazing mashup rebel
princess Lola
since Disney bought Star Wars Princess
Leia is technically a Disney princess
and since the loud family is full of
fierce female characters just like Leia
we love this mashup this is another Lola
fan art from oh four star D corn on line
88 and this time they even included a My
Little Pony character both Leia
Skywalker and Lola loud our princesses
who get exactly what they want they're
strong independent ladies who aren't
afraid to use their skills Hey Leia
starts with an L maybe she could just be
adopted by the loud family we are loving
the intergalactic hairstyle on Lola this
is one creative artist loud royal family
we love that discordant princess from
deviantART took a different approach in
her fan art mashup these loud sisters
look way more like they belong on a
Disney movie than some of the other art
first up we have Lauri loud as
Cinderella she looks fabulous but Lauri
isn't quite as soft spoken at sooner
Ella Lennie loudest feature here at
Aurora from Sleeping Beauty we think she
looks great in the pink and white ball
gown her white sunglasses would totally
match and Luna makes a great Ariel
because they both March or swim to the
beat of their own drum we wonder what
Nick's swagger would look like as a
merman the loud princesses this
deviantART mashup is so perfect this
time we see some of the loud sisters
looking like they played Disney dress-up
lenny seems totally perfect as
Cinderella after all
they both have a hobby of fashion design
Lauri looks fantastic with her hair as
black as coal like Snow White cubed and
we can see the land matched up with
Belle again we love how creative cartoon
admire is they entered this drawing in a
cosplay illustration
these are the perfect cosplays for these
loud sisters keep watching to see the
most creative lab house and Disney
Princess mashup we found sleeping Lola
Lola loud is one of the most fun
characters to mashup with the Disney
princess because she's already such a
princess here her pink style is matched
up with an Aurora style pink gown don't
you think they both look smashing in
pink we aren't sure how Lola would have
handled being raised as an only child in
the forest there aren't exactly a lot of
beauty pageants out there we love how
artists Pogo rekey fan 10 may Lola's
tiara much fancier and used the sash to
enhance the gown so stylish
we don't think Lola would have been the
type to end up asleep for centuries but
the fan art is amazing Elsa flower the
loud house is a very unique animation
style mostly we've seen loud house
characters turned in at Disney
Princesses but artist EA gc7 drew Elsa
from frozen in the style of our favorite
Nickelodeon cartoon Elsa is wearing her
classic ice cream dress but looks
exactly like a member of the loud family
it only makes sense to cross over one of
the most popular Disney characters with
one of the most popular Nickelodeon
shows this artist did a great job
capturing the essence of both we think
Elsa would be a cool addition to the
loud house see what we did there lenny
loud let down your hair we absolutely
adore this crossover of Lenny loud and
Rapunzel just like Lenny
Rapunzel can be a little ditzy although
it's not her fault she grew up locked in
a tower
they're both stylish blondes with many
talents and we feel like obsessively
rushing her hair is something Lenny
would do artists reform Ralphie tops off
Lenny's princess look with her signature
white sunglasses and princess or not we
wouldn't expect anything less of Lenny
we know Rapunzel would have loved
growing up with ten siblings you know if
she hadn't been kidnapped by an evil
witch and all this is one of our
absolute favorite matches loud family
goes royal and now we've reached the
most creative fan art mashup of the loud
house and Disney Princesses this
deviantART artist is definitely a
loud house fan and we think they did a
perfect job artist Cassie Liu drew this
amazing crossover and included so much
detail first up we have Luria's Ariel
who is smitten over a statue of Bobby
then we have Lenny as Aurora
we love how the artist drew the dress
from all three fairy godmothers that is
so Lenny both Luna and Rapunzel played
guitar so this is the perfect combo and
we love that LuAnn as Belle has a puppet
of the Beast which loud house and Disney
Princess combo would you create let us
know in the comments and that's all of
the awesome fan art we have today if you
love the loud house and Disney be sure
to check out our community page for more
great content and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]